大家好,我是赵产,目前是在负责新战机密计算远程证明服务开发相关的工作。
今天给大家分享的课程主题是,新战机密计算远程证明服务,构建数据要素流通的信任基础。
整个课程的大纲狼,首先我们会从最基础的需求分析开始,一步步了解远程证明的工作原理。
最后我们会介绍标准的时间方法和新战机密计算远程证明服务的时间方法。
之后我们会通过跨于广控的真实的数据按键,展示数据在被证明的可信环境下的一个流通过程,更直观的感受到数据是如何流通运动的。
最后我们还会一起掌望一下未来探讨一下跨云统一证明的一个可能性。
我们都知道数据已经成为了这个当代现代数字经济的一个核心的生产要素,数据的安全流通就是释放其价值的关键。
当数据在不同的实体之间传递的时候,它会离开原来的控制范围,如果数据在流通过程中得不到一个安全的保障,那么它的价值将无法顺利传递。
机密计算技术通过创建一个可信的执行环境,它就像一个黑盒子,利用软硬件的隔离和可信技术能够确保数据在不被看到的情况下安全使用。
虽然机密计算可以通过可信执行环境来保护数据,但接收方,它怎么确认自己连接的是真正的一个可因症环境,而不是一个模拟的假的环境呢?
这就是远程证明技术发挥作用的地方,它是解决这个信任最后一公里问题的这么一个关键技术。
换句话说,机密计算技术为我们提供的这个数据安全使用的保障而远程证明技术,就是帮助我们确认这个保障是否真是可靠的。
杨德一结合,就共同确保了数据在流通过程中的安全性和价值的传递。
那么我们该如何从一个模糊的信任,然后转变一种可以验证的信任呢?
从安全的视角来看,一切的信任都是使用硬件,取一个例子。
CPU或者是TPM中有一个被称为熔断密钥的装置。
这个密钥是芯片制造商在生产过程中预先设置好的,它都没有办法导出了。
接着这个密钥通过权威机构,生成一层一层数字讯书,可以进行验证和背书,就形成了一个完整的信任链条。
这个链条涵盖来从芯片,然后固件,可信执行环境,到用程序的整个过程。
最后是变成验证的一个基石。
简单来说呢,硬件是信任的起点,然后我们可以通过一层层的验证和背书逐渐建立起一个完整的信任链条。
确保你的运行的设备和用程序都是安全并且符合预期的。
然后最后通过预期的结果,然后再做下一步的授权。
当然,要让别人信任你,让得靠技术来保证。
接下来我们会详细讲讲原证明是怎么实现的,大致整个流程是这样。
在整个流程中呢,大致封围这么几个角色。
首先,验证方,也就是我们的远程证明服务器。
T1节点,可信执行环境,可信硬件,類似IGX,TPM等等。
CA服务,也就是我们的权威的一个认证机构。
首先,验证方会给T1节点发送一个随机制服串,我们叫做Lounge。
接着,T1节点会在生成度量环境之后产生一份报告。
这份报告会发给可信硬件,用来生成一个叫做Code的签名。
然后,T1节点会把这份报告发给验证方,验证服务器来进验证。
在验证过程中,验证方会调用证书办法机构。
CA来验证报告中的证书链,是否有效。
接着,验证方会从证书里面把公要取出来来去验证报告的签名,
确保T1节点是一个可信的节点,是符合预期的节点。
这又是一个远人证明的过程。
简单来说,我们可以把这个流程抽象成几个层次来看。
首先是最底层的硬件层,这个硬件层会生成原始的一个度量报告。
第二层是协议层。
协议层是一个标准化的,会定义这个报告的格式。
比如说我们标准的ITS,我们后面会讲到。
然后第三层就是云端的服务层。
云端的服务层主要是用来处理,对这些报告进行一个处理和验证。
然后最上面一层就是应用层。
也就是应用会使用SDK消费这些验证结果,用来做一些权限或者决策。
为了让这个流程更加的清晰,统一清晰,我们需要一个非常标准化的架构来支持。
目前国际上ITF推出了ITS框架,正好在做这个事情。
ITS目标其实很简单。
第一,它是打破了各个技术之间的隔阂。
比如像Intel SX,AMDX,UV,华为,昆彭等不同的硬件厂商。
它只可以使用环境的能够用同一种方式来进行交流。
第二是统一了标准的流程,把各个零散的这种验证方法整合成了一个通用的,可以互操作的一个框架。
第三,给设备颁发了一个可信的身份证,就像人使用身份证证明我是我的问题。
设备就可以通过ITS这套机制来证明自己。
这个系统主要依靠三个角色来运作。
首先是证明者Attest。
这个角色在需要验证的设备上进行工作。
它的任务是利用可信执行环境的芯片,制作一个硬件级别的一个不可随意创改的报告。
那就是Report。
另外,这个角色就是验证者,Wirefile,这个角色是新的核心,它负责两个设备。
第一个设备就是验证这个体检报告,是不是真的。
然后,会根据验证的结果,签发一个标准化的一个健康证书。
也就是我们所说的这个EAT令牌,一个token。
第三个呢,就是E-Line Party这个角色。
也就是你的业务系统,它只看这个健康证书来决定,是否进行一个敏感的一个操作。
当然,要让这个架构能够顺利的落地,我们需要两大关键的一个基础设施来进行支持。
首先是机密计算,它能够为我们打造一个安全的可靠的一个执行环境。
另外一个就是可信底座,它就像一个信任的一个基石吧,
为我们的系统提供一个可靠的一个信任的保障。
最良的结合呢,就给我们的架构上,就像给我们的架构加上一个双保险,为数据安全流通保驾护航。
首先,我们来看一看就是新战机密计算。
新战机密计算是蚂蚁命算制组研发了一项数据保护的一项方案。
它有独特的技术和知识产权,它不仅能够弥补国产CPU在安全性上的不足,
还能将信任建立在我们的国家的一个基础设置之上,通过使用普及的硬件设备。
这个方案还能够显著降低用户的使用成本,同时也提供强大和灵活的一个机密计算和隐形式计算的服务。
在数据处理过程中,它能够实现数据可用不可见的安全特性,确保数据安全。
这个方案大致分为三个层次,首先是安全底座,安全操作系统和可信技术设施。
这三个模块紧密协作,从底层安全蓄力化到上层可信服务冷件站,构建出了一套完整的系统。
这个系统能够支持大规模和复杂的一个数据扭转的场景,能够满足各种机密计算和隐形计算的一个需求。
我们的可信技术设施是一套云原生的一套解决方案,专门为提供安全的可音指引环境的能力。
它结合了机密讯理机和卡特容器,通过KVS平台就像管理普通的应用一样。
轻松来管理机密应用的生命周期,还能够显著减少可音指引环境的新设施的TCB。
此外,我们自己还开发了一套T1的操作系统。
它能够对应用的企论过程中的进行一个度量,把新设施从平台扯,衍生到处理数据的应用场,建立了一个比较完整的新设施,解决了传统可音指引环境的平台,新设施不足的一个问题。
另外,这套系统还包括两个比较核心的服务。
第一个是密钥管理服务,另外一个就是远人证明服务。
远人证明服务负责验证可音指引环境应用的可信度,验证通过之后会给应用办法一个可信身份。
密钥管理服务则根据这个身份来保证密钥授权的一个策略,确保只有被授权的应用才能获取效应的密钥。
那么我们再来看看新占可信技术设施,安全可信能力是如何来实现的。
前面我们讲过可信的新人的某点是基于可信硬件,TPM硬件可信根就是整个系统的一个新能基础。
当这个超系统启动的时候,它会把这个启动组件的一些度量值呢,记录到TPM的PCR基层启动。
然后呢,出示的文件系统呢,它会加在这个驱动模块,驱动模块会加在我们的这个蓄力化组件,HIPHUNCLEV,
并且呢,会把这个启动的度量值呢,也会记录到这个TPM的一个PCR基层启动。
当这个HIPHUNCLEV启动的启动之后呢,会把这个超系统降级为这个非透浅模式,作为这个机密蓄力机的一个可信根。
这个时候呢,再来建立这个机密蓄力机的这个启动链,包括这个TPM,客厅内核,以及内核的一些密利航组件。
确保这个机密蓄力机的这个启动组件呢,都是符合预期的。
同时呢,这个系统的这个RUT-FF分区呢,也会被这个DeviceMaple,这个RVT这个机制呢,保护这个完整性。
另外呢,分区的一个根哈器呢,也会被这个内核的密利航进行一个保护,这样呢,就从这个机密蓄力机的这个启动链扩展到这个整个系统服务。
那,应用容器,它会被这个系统服务的组件来启动。
所以,启动的组件呢,它会借助这个系统的这个MA进行一个完整性的涂量,以及神机,还有一些安全评估。
如果安全检查失败,那么这个容器将会被阻止来阻止运行。
那,应用容器启动之后呢,会通过远人证明这个机制来检查这个平台和远人证明的这个证明报告。
这样一来呢,就能把这个启动链传遞到这个运用程。
那我们再来看看这个机密硬件的这个新人链是如何被验证的。
那新人链决定了整个这个可信的验证体系,从前面我们了解到新人关系是怎么从硬件传遞到的容器用的。
在使用这个远人证明的时候,那么我们最终检查的是应用的一个涂量日子。
所以远人证明报告中的这个涂量日子必须是完整靠谱的。
那,据你来说,那个HIPHOP CORT的真实性要靠这个硬件标签名来验证。
而容器中的代码的内机涂量值呢,要靠这个CORT平台中的这个RTM2来保证。
RTM2的这个涂量值呢,有平台的这个签名来保证。
同时呢,签名的工药呢,也需要被这个TPM的这个硬件的这个PCR来保证。
这样呢,新人链就从这个可信硬件传遞到的容器应用程,确保这个系统启动的时候,
是从主机到,到虚拟机,再到容器的任何的组件都是经过完整验证的。
那,远人证明服务的设计呢,符合这个标准微服务的这个三层架构,
分为这个核心层,服务层,以及接口层。
那,核心层这个设计呢,它主要是以这个动态插件形式的存在,
它能够兼容并验证来自不同核心执行环境,比如像HIPHOP GLEEB,Intel的TDX,
后面我们也会对这个GPU的这个认证来做一个支持。
另外呢,这个设计呢,还允许动态去添加一个新的这个可以自行环境的验证一个插件。
那,服务层呢,包括这个机线策略和正确的管理来管理主机平台和应用这三种角色的这个认证者的一个几个机线,
并支持了这个多版本的机型管理,然后另外就是身份管理,然后支持这个,
吸力度的这个防控者,审计和追踪,并且统一的这个标准的这个,并且使用了这个标准的这个488ID的这么一个身份标识,
来做这个快的新人的管理,另外一个就是GV这个度量结果的一个身份签发的一个管理,
然后通过这个签发这个token的密要呢,主要是通过这个硬件来拍摄的,然后另外呢,提供了这个可行审计的能力,
然后确保这个VS在运营的时候的一些运行日治,以度量结果能够被审计,
然后另外一块就是那个API接口程,主要提供了这个机线的注册和审计日的查询,
其中图的最左侧就是它是可以来自这个不同证明者,不同角色的证明者,
主要成为主机平台和应用的商场角色,因为他们之间,我刚刚前面也说了他们之间是一个担保关系,
最终它是以这个tpm的硬件来进行担保的,当这有attest的这个报告发送到这个远证明服了之后,
然后对这个包包进行出生解析,解析完之后,然后通过这个证明者插件进行一个验证,验证的过程中呢,
然后通过这个配置的机线的参考值进行一个比对,如果验证成功呢,会把这个验证的结果通过这个可行硬件的这个密要呢进行一个token的签发,
并且把token签发的结果呢,然后还给这个应用程来做进行一个消费,然后最右层的主要是对这种商场角色的这个这个这个,
呃,使用者的然后进行一个机线的配置,在我们之前的这个讨论中呢,我们了解到远人证明服务,他可以为这个应用来提供这个可行身份,
那么机民应用是怎么来去获取这个可行应用身份,以及他们是怎么来消费这个可行身份的呢,那么我们来看左侧这个图,应用a和应用b,
应用a这个时候,他起动的时候,首先他会向这个呃,远人证明服务器发起一个平台的这么一个身份请求,
当然应用a不能直接跟远人证明服务器进行交货,首先他需要通过这个,呃testing agent来去做一个带你做进一个转发,
因为attesting agent他会采集这个平台的这个这个度量值来去做一个,先做一个平台的远人证明请求,
当远人证明服务器收到这个平台远人证明的这么一个请求之后呢,他会把这个平台的这个报告解说来,先做一个验证,验证完之后呢,
然后他首先会这个平台办发一个jwt,因为jwt目前是一个他是一个无证出的模式,
所以在返回的时候,他需要用这个远人证明服务器的报告来对这个jwt的公要进行一个担保,
以避免在这个jwt在传说的过程中呢,被中连人进行一个攻击来对公要进行一个替换,
这个时候attesting agent他会对这个vast的这个report进行一个教练,教练完之后呢,然后会把这个公要暂时先缓存起来,
这个时候attesting agentA呢,这个时候会发起一个应用的一个一个身份请求,这个时候报告里面既包括了这个平台的这个这个报告也包括了这个应用的报告,
其中应用的报告是通过平台的报告来做一个担保,当这个远人证明服务器这个收到这个报告之后呢,
他首先会把平台的这个报告解出来,然后进行一个教练,然后再把这个应用的报告再解出来进行一个教练,
并且和这个配置的这个机械进行一个比对,然后比对完之后呢,然后会给这个应用了,来办发一个一个一个jwt的token,
这个时候这个jwt里面是不带不带的公要,他会把这个jwt直接返给这个attesting agentA,这个时候attesting agentA会把这个jwt返给这个应用A,
这个时候应用A拿到了这个token之后呢,他会把这个会写在他自己的优务数据,然后发给应用B,
应用B收到这个jwt之后呢,他会去先教练这个A是不是一个合法的应用,然后他怎么教练呢,他会把这个jwt的这个token掉到这个远人接口,
然后掉到他自己的这个对应的这个attesting agentB来做一个教练,
因为之前B也拿到了这个这个平台这个公要,我平台的公要是可以验证这个jwt的这个签名的,
所以他可以确定这个jwt的这个签名的合法性,并把验证结果,然后发给这个应用B来确定,
如果验证成功呢,那么后面可以确认身份,他可以访问这个他所对应的这个业务逻辑,
如果验证不通过呢,表示这是一个访冒的这个身份,并且返回这个臭马,
基于上面那个流程呢,放到整个平台空间输入要输的流程场景中呢,
远人证明服务是如何来帮助应用来实现快逸真正的呢,
快逸广控的关键在于管理可信执行环境中的应用的身份来确保这个用物发送到密算平台的环境是可被验证的,
以及数据在流程过程中的数据和密要设备保护的,
首先密算平台利用可信硬件,保障了这个可信的启动,
骑士利用了这个可信执行环境来保护数据集团过程中的这个完整性和机密性,
同时的利用硬件可信跟和远人证明服务呢,我们可以验证平台和应用的一个可信,
从而确保的数据在不同的主体之间的一个安全扭转,
这张图里面用户请求远人认证,而远人认证担保了这个数字信封里面这个公要在传输过程中的一个完整性,
当用户拿到这个远人认证报告之后呢,可以通过全ACA来去验证这个报告,
里面的证书,然后再通过这个证书来验证这个报告的这么一个合法性,
然后再通过这个报告来确定这个数字信封这个公要的一个合法性,
然后用户拿到这个公要之后呢,可以对他加密数据的这个对签密要进行一个加密,
然后把加密之后呢,数据的合密要传输到这个遇传平台,遇传平台拿出到这个加密之后的结果呢,
首先会通过这个数字信封的这个私要来解除,
之前用这个公要加密的这个对签密要,然后把对签密要解除了之后呢,
然后对这个数据进行一个解密,然后再对这个数据进行一个加工处理,
这样就保证了这个数据在跨意的时候的这个传输的一个安全性。
这个整体方案还充分考虑了这个,因为过程中可能存在了一个安全动作,
它能够抵御这个管理员和高特权级的一个软件的二语攻击,
我们构建了一个以技术为技术的这么一个新的体系,
实现了数据使用权的一个跨意管控,
总体来说呢,远程证明在这个过程中,
扮演了一个非常重要的角色,
确保了数据流通的这个安全性和可靠性。
当我们聊到这个数据快译的问题的时候呢,
多音环境的复杂性是一个绕不开的话题,
在那个多音的环境之中呢,不同的云平台的独立性和多样性都带来的不少的一个挑战,
每个云平台基本上都有自己的一个安全车连,
在这个数据管理的方式和独特的新人体系,
这些独立运作的这个新人孤岛呢,
给跨云的数据流通带来了一些阻碍,
虽然有些企业选择的使用多音平台来优化支援配置,
以及提高数据的可靠性,
但云平台之间的互操作问题,
就让这个数据的无缝流通呢,
变得非常的棘手。
这些新人孤岛不仅阻碍了这个数据的实施,
共享和协作处理呢,
也增加了数据泄漏和合规的风险,
为了更加顺畅的数据流动,
我们需要找到方法来打破这些新人孤岛,
实现更高效,更安全的一个数据,
跨域,共享的方法。
为了解决这个问题呢,
我们需要建立一个统一的这个新人烟人框架,
和一个数据这里机制,
让这个统一证明解决方案呢,
像一个万人的实斃器,
通过这个统一的协同烟人框架的,
标准化的协议和抽象中间成了,
让不同的可引植性环境的架构,
实现这个协议翻译,
然后在这个技术上呢,
我们再建立一个监管的一个制止系统,
比如利用这个区块链的存证技术来确保这个,
服务器的运行记录和烟人结果,
不可创改,
并通过这个审讯接口呢,
实施满足这个,数据监管的一个需求,
最终为这个数据流通提供一个安全可靠的,
这么一个通用基础,
这样一来呢,比如医院在获取这个,
患者的这个跨机后数据的时候呢,
就不需要在为每个厂商单独做这个,
安全适配,
最终呢,数据就可以安全顺畅的在不同的云,
和不同的区域之间,
流动,
当然我们最终的目标是利用这些技术,
来建立一个涵盖所有领域的一个,
新的网络,
目前呢,现在密泰计算资源很少,
然后价格也很高,
用户的使用门槛也很高,
所以我们后面会支持各种不同平台和,
多音环境,
用最低层面的方式,
把计算资源都变成密算节点,
让用户的这个,
应用的工作复杂,
在多个云平台上,
来降低这个使用门槛,
这些密算节点呢,
它可以通过这个,
统一的这个原证明,
互相信任,互相连接,
和互相通信,
最终形成这个,
密泰天空计算网络结构,
在这个结构之中呢,
用户的工作复杂呢,
就可以互相协作,
调度平稳的签议,
数据呢,
就可以像,
在云环境中一样,
安全的一个,
可信和流动,
最终呢,让数据的价值呢,
像自然水一样,
即开即用,
以上就是我要分享的所有的内容,
谢谢大家。